[TRAFFIC NOISE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
ADDY: So the web is getting fat.
Accidental slowness is a
problem that a lot of us face.
You, in the general slowness,
most people in the performance
side of the things.
MATT: That's fair.
I deserved that.
ADDY: Performance is important.
MATT: Yeah.
ADDY: Like, it's very
easy to go and ship
a site that contains
a ton of images
and not realize just how slow
that is, especially on mobile,
where people have got, like,
limited network connections
and limited bandwidth.
MATT: And this is where the
picture elements also-- they're
kind of coming in to
help with all of this
but it still-- there
are still images
that have to be downloaded.
ADDY: Even then,
people should probably
have a good image optimization
workflow inside their
build pipeline.
Just something
simple to make sure
that you're trimming down
the fat of what you're
shipping down to your users.
MATT: Well, because you never
really notice a difference
anyway.
It's just literally free
time that you were just
saving a user.
ADDY: No.
MATT: Yeah.
So what do you use to
optimize all your images?
ADDY: So I usually use--
in my build process--
I'm usually using something like
Imagemin, which is a tool that
can figure out-- like, it's
got some opinionated choices
about how to optimize images
like PNGs and JPEGs and GIFs.
I think it's using, like,
OptiPNG and JPEGmini,
and Gifsicle.
MATT: Yeah.
ADDY: But if all of
that sounds totally
crazy to you, another
really nice desktop tool
is ImageOptim.
MATT: Yep.
ADDY: So ImageOptim is
cool, because it just
means that you just take
a directory of images,
drop it in, it'll do some
magic, and you can just
re-upload them.
You're done.
MATT: So I mostly
use Grunt Imagemin.
I use all of that, and it
works absolutely great.
I've seen ImageOptim.
That's great whenever
I'm doing prototypes.
Just drop it in there.
The one thing that
I've ended up doing
is using ImageMagick
to auto-generate images
of different sizes.
ADDY:Right.
MATT: They've actually
got a strip metadata
command in there,
and it literally
does a lot of what
some of the tools do,
so it's just at
least stripping out
some of the additional
stuff that's not needed.
ADDY: When you're talking
about stripping stuff out,
you talk about,
like, SVG, I guess,
where you've got
a ton of metadata
that tools usually include.
MATT: Yes.
It's just like, oh, this is
made by Inkscape or Sketch.
It's just like,
the person doesn't
care that's viewing it--
ADDY: Yeah.
MATT: --so get rid of it.
The obvious other
tool is WebPagetest.
ADDY: So WebPagetest
is kind of awesome.
Really, really helps
with, like, making sure
that you're hitting
decent speed index scores.
Quick tip there-- if
you're trying to, like,
do any sort of
benchmarking WebPagetest,
and you just do a single--
a single run multiple times
over-- you might
find that there's
a bit of a difference in scores.
So WebPagetest has
this advanced option
where you could run the same
test multiple times over,
then just average out the stuff.
I use that.
Find it pretty reliable.
Maybe you would too?
MATT: Yeah, I tend to
find that WebPagetest
is almost like PageSpeed
Insights, but just on speeds.
It's just you've got
so many more options,
so much more details.
And, depending on
where you are in terms
of trying to trim
performance, WebPagetest
is great for highlighting
simple things,
like, hey, you know what, you
should be enabling compression
with just GZIP, and it's just,
like, that is a one-line change
in a hasty access file.
WebPagetest is literally
like, yo, you're not even
getting your first
file down to here
or your first render isn't
until, like, three seconds in.
ADDY: The video filmstrip
in WebPagetest is amazing.
MATT: Yeah.
ADDY: Really, really
useful for, saying, OK,
how many seconds
is it going to take
before my user can actually
even interact with my page?
MATT: Yeah.
ADDY: Good for
[? perceived ?] performance,
good for just being
able to see what
your users are going to see.
MATT: One last thing I'm
going to say about WebPagetest
they've just added in is
the cost of your site.
And it literally just says
this is the number megabytes.
This is what it equates to.
Someone in that country
downloading your site.
Like for me, it's $0.22
from "Venoowata," Vanuatu--
I don't know-- somewhere.
And it's just, like--
it's interesting,
because if you've got a massive,
huge site with tons of images,
people in other countries
may not actually
be able to afford
viewing your site.
Anyway, I ran your site
through PageSpeed Insights.
ADDY: Oh, no.
MATT: And someone was doing
a little cheeky, small bit
of cheating, really, aren't you?
ADDY: I wouldn't
call it cheating.
I would say I'm giving
people a fast path to see--
MATT: A fast path.
ADDY: --to seeing my home page.
MATT: So you've added in
a site, which is basically
very limited in functionality to
increase your PageSpeed score,
haven't you?
ADDY: Someone called it a
landing page or a hero page.
MATT: Because when you actually
run it, addyosmani.com,
what happens is, you've
actually got a redirect--
you should never have a
redirect for any website--
ADDY: No, no, you shouldn't.
MATT: --if you can avoid it.
And your one goes,
addyosmani.com,
that jumps to
www.addyosmani.com/blog
ADDY: I like-- I like to see--
MATT: That then goes to
www.addyosmanni.com/blog/,
so there's a slash on the
end, that's important.
And then it's gone
addyosmani.com/blog/,
so you've managed to go
from your home page to three
different versions
of your blog URL.
ADDY: I like to think
of my site as a learning
ground for anti-practices.
[MUSIC PLAYING]